Dead Space is a space Horror Story where
humans stumble upon an alien
civilization called Necromorphs that
infest and multiply through human hosts
these aliens are all part of one hive
mind that use a mysterious marker to
send signals and hallucinations into his
Targets in order to spread while that's
a decent surface level telling of the
overall idea there's far more to it from
cult-like religious zealots to
government interference and more this is
the story of Dead Space explained
chapter one in Alien Discovery while
Dead Space takes place in the year 2508
all of this begins way back in 2214. you
see by 2214 Earth is in a rough Place
Humanity have nearly depleted all of
Earth's resources and are searching for
any means by which they can continue to
obtain or mine these in digging up the
Gulf of Mexico The Sovereign colonies
and predecessor to Earth government or
earthgov happens upon a black alien
marker while they have no idea where
this is from or how it got here the
truly exciting thing for The Sovereign
colonies is that it seems to continually
produce some form of energy maybe just
maybe if they study it they can
reproduce the marker and solve Earth's
energy crisis there's a catch however
the black marker signal that it
continually emanates seems to cause
hallucinations dementia psychosis and
and one other little
minor side effect that you may notice
while playing dead space if you really
squint it causes dead human tissue to
reanimate and re-emerge as horrifying
Twisted corpses all with the single mind
and single Focus these reanimated
corpses are dubbed Necromorphs and they
all seem to be controlled by a singular
hive mind attempting to gather as much
tissue as possible in order to grow but
you see it could solve the energy crisis
so ignoring all of that because it's
such a minor minor little detail The
Sovereign colonies decides to try and
recreate the marker and successfully
reverse engineer it creating a second
red marker
now install the singularity core on the
shuttle I'll come help you load the
marker they send this red marker off
planet to ages 7 in order to safely test
and study it of course this causes a
catastrophic event to such a degree that
The Sovereign colonies seals away the
marker in ages 7 and berries all of the
records They sealed off the whole system
buried the records nice and clean
until CEC got greedy around the same
time back on Earth the original black
marker was eventually investigated by a
geophysicist named Michael Altman Altman
let the world know about the black
marker which Earth government had also
covered up he claimed it was the biggest
cover-up ever instituted by earthgov and
that approved beyond a shadow of a doubt
that there is in fact alien life the
government labeled him a kook and he
died of mysterious circumstances shortly
afterwards however the seat of doubt
he'd planted even though it was truthful
would Sprout into something horrendous
chapter 2 unitology
while Altman had no direct involvement
with the founding of the religion of
unitology it was fueled and started by
those around him and corrupt government
officials who believed his message about
the marker and felt there was a higher
calling likely with their beliefs
distorted and stemming from the marker
itself as their beliefs do align with
what the markers seems to need the name
alone unitology aligns with the marker
and Necromorphs and being of a hive mind
these unitologists believe and I'm going
to directly quote the game here the
marker contained code the key to eternal
life through rebirth and Ascension to
heaven the kicker is you have to die
first they believe in an Ascension event
called the conversions not unlike many
religions like judeo-christians who
believe humans eventually Ascend to
heaven after death while on its surface
the religion seems fairly harmless the
unitologists believe that Altman was a
martyr and his martyrdom was meant to
spread the religion they believe it in a
conspiracy that the government is hiding
the marker to keep its secrets for
itself and they function a little bit
less like judeo-christians and a little
more like Scientology and that they have
a ranking system the more money and
power you give them the higher you rank
up in the religion the unitologists have
also built Mausoleum ships where they
gathered their Believers corpses all
meant to travel in space to a marker for
a great ascendance so when you consider
the markers purposefully trying to
gather dead tissue in order to transform
beings into Necromorphs and expand and
build its own hive mind sending in ships
filled to the brim with Corpses
probably not good
chapter 3 planet cracking going back to
the dwindling resources and dying Earth
Earth gov eventually found its solution
in Planet cracking and this is where the
USG ishimura and where Dead Space remake
takes place comes into play because
Earth is out of resources Earth and
private companies begin to look to the
Stars What If instead of robbing the
Earth of its resources you could Rob
other planets of the resources and use
them for your own that was the very real
dream of CEC or Concordance extraction
Corporation CEC according to its
investor guide which I thoroughly read
as a proud investor in CEC and someone
who has made a huge amount of money on
their stock is the largest solar Mining
and extraction company in the earth
colonies and the fifth largest
Interstellar company in terms of Market
Capital while there already were similar
vessels that were being sent to create
colonies on planets for mining resources
the CEC came up with a way to dismantle
planets and moons on a macro scale
utilizing a planner cracker ship that
could fracture planets with gravity
tethers and then quickly mine the entire
planet for its resources with the very
minor trade-off of destroying an entire
planet in the process according to
environmentalists potentially even
destroyed the solar system or disrupt
the gravitational forces holding
celestial objects in orbit and cause it
to spin out of control or plan is to
collide into each other anyways in order
to successfully crack a planet the CEC
would first scope out a planet for its
mineral content and net worth plus the
overall safety of cracking it in the
first place after choosing his Planet
they then set up a small Colony on the
designated planet where a team would
spend 18 months prepping the planet for
a planet cracking ship after around two
and a half to three years the planet
cracker would arrive and giant tectonic
chunks of the planet are broken off and
mined while smaller bodies like
asteroids are drawn into mining bays and
processed directly rinse and repeat
until no more planets these plan
cracking ships would become a reality in
2446 with the very first launch of the
bunch the USG ishimura chapter 4 Isaac's
backstory fast forwarding once again we
come to our main protagonist Isaac Clark
his father Paul Clark was an
award-winning ship architect employed by
the galactic Union Merchant Marine Corps
however Paul was regularly out on
various missions leaving his mother
Octavia Clark to raise Isaac mostly on
her own Octavia ended up becoming
enamored with the church of unitology so
much so she sold off most of the
family's estate to fund a full
membership into the church and in order
to rank up in it as she spends so much
of their money on unitology while Isaac
was such a strong student in mechanical
and electrical engineering and even got
into prestigious engineering school he
had to instead attend a lesser-known
school with the help of scholarships and
financial assistance Isaac enlisted in
the Merchant Marine and quickly moved up
the ranks thanks to his strong
engineering skills and intuition however
his mother's mental Health declined
further and she ended up in a hospital
and under the care of the
neuropsychiatrist Nicole Brennan while
treating his mother Nicole and Isaac
fell in love and cohabitated for a time
however Nicole was offered a promotion
serving aboard the USG ishimura while
avia's six-month job and time away from
Isaac Isaac petitioned she take the job
likely being supportive of her career
around this time Nicole felt that
Isaac's mother had finally gotten better
and it was time for her to return home
to her family where his father had
recently come home from an extended tour
Isaac's mother relapsed killed Paul and
then herself
she killed my dad and herself
from her own will the unitologists were
given custody of their corpses along
with Clark's entire estate Isaac
petitioned for his parents bodies to be
returned to him but to no avail he also
got into a fight with Nicole where he
essentially blamed her for what happened
and allowing his mother to be released
from the hospital all of this coinciding
with what would be the USG ishimura's
final mission
chapter 5 the ishimura's final mission
the year is 2508 and the ishimora has
been sent on a supposed Planet cracking
mission to ages 7. the very same planet
that the red marker was buried on
however that's not exactly all correct a
CEC director Eckhart sees over the
planet cracking Mission and while it's
not stated directly in the Dead Space
remake it can be heavily inferred that
he's a unitologist
unitologists have been searching for the
red marker for a while and it seems
they've finally figured out where it is
so Eckard assigns another unitology
buddy of his to Captain the ushi
ishimura on this mission Captain
Benjamin Matthias and ages 7 is actually
off limits by earthgov so the true
purpose and destination of this Mission
seems to be a complete lie and kept
under the wraps as for Planet cracking
protocol the CEC starts a colony on ages
7 to prep it for Planet cracking and
more specifically search for their real
goal the red marker all of this I have
to ascertain is also fully secret and
kept from earthgov Captain Matthias is
given the goal by Chief unitologist of
obtaining the marker from Asia 7 and
safely delivering it to the Church of
unitology all of this so he can be given
one of the most elite Church of
unitology rank UPS there is after his
death being put in a premium stasis
capsule aboard the church's holy Fleet
which of course will be on its way to be
part of that super cool goopy hive mind
Mass meanwhile the USG ishimura is then
staffed with a large number of
unitologists in senior positions notably
this includes the chief science officer
Dr Terence kind and Dr chalice Mercer as
the ishimura reaches its destination of
Ages 7 just like the black marker in
events from 2214 as they dig up the red
marker people on The Colony start to
experience hallucinations visions and
begin transforming into Necromorphs due
to this it seems though a unitologist Dr
kind cautions against immediately
grabbing the Parker he knows that all of
the hysteria started after the marker
was dug up and wants to study this
further before leaping to taking it on
board in fact forty percent of the
colonies population are showing symptoms
Captain Matthias ignores this and the
ishimora is successful in obtaining the
marker and bringing it aboard the ship
due to the epidemic that they don't
fully realize is from the marker Captain
Matthias orders a quarantine on ages 7
and refuses to help any of the survivors
Dr kinda Nicole quickly realized that
it's the marker causing all of the
horrors that are happening before them
Captain Matthias cuts off all the
communications of the outside world and
due to all of this Dr kind and others
plan a mutiny against Captain Matthias
kind accidentally kills him in the
process though and all hell proceeds to
break out on the ship from here Mercer
begins a pro-marker faction along with
the many many unitologists on board
where he experiments on various
unitologists and other people suffering
from the marker's effects in order to
try and create stronger Necromorphs and
help himself to achieve ascendance other
members of the ship resign themselves to
their deadly faith and decide that they
can't let this horror spread back on
Earth they self-sabotage the ship and
attempt to force the ship to collide
with ages seven in order to destroy
themselves the hive mind and the marker
with it
Dr kind is of the belief that bringing
the marker back to Asia 7 will stop
everything he believes the marker calms
and quells the hive mind and Nicole
after doing her best to fight against
Mercer treat patience and fight against
unitology overall messages Isaac and
sadly kills herself chapter 6 Dead Space
which leads nicely into the game itself
where Isaac has either blocked the final
portion of this video out due to grief
or guilt or simply forgotten it due to
the influence of the marker the CEC
receives the USG ishimura's distress
signal and a small crew aboard the USG
kelian head out to see what's going on
and help the crew consists of Zach
Hammond the chief security officer and
head of the mission pilot Aiden Chen
co-pilot Johnston and Kendra Daniels
who's secretly a part of earthgov coming
to clean up the mess her mission is to
retrieve the marker and relocate it on a
brand new planet that earthgov can hide
the marker away on meanwhile cover up
what happened and here on the ishimura
and probably just let it all burn the
USM Valor a destroyer class vessel is
also sent to help retrieve the marker
LED in part by Kendra however as Isaac's
team reaches the ishimora they begin to
realize the true extent of what has
happened there even Kendra who had read
reports of what the marker could cause
attributed it to mass hysteria and
didn't truly believe the accounts
everything is far worse than any of them
could have predicted Hammond ends up
ejecting a noun Necromorph Chen out of
an escape pod which the USM Valor ends
up picking up Necromorph Chen ends up
killing all of them and turning them all
into Necromorphs in the end Hammond Chen
and Johnston all end up dying the sole
survivors we know of are Isaac Kendra Dr
Mercer Dr kind and Dr Elizabeth cross
who works in Hydroponics the marker
plays a strange hallucination on Isaac
and Dr cross where they think the other
is their lost lover
you both
[Music]
of Jacob Temple for her and Nicole for
you Isaac views Elizabeth as Nicole in
his mind and Elizabeth sees Isaac as her
lost lover and also engineer Jacob
Temple Mercer ends up dying at the hands
of his own beloved Necromorphs meanwhile
Dr kind convinces Isaac and Elizabeth to
bring the marker back to ages seven
Kendra who works with earthgov and
therefore wants to relocate the marker
is against this so she kills Dr kind and
attempts to take it away herself sorry
Isaac I couldn't trust him with the
marker Isaac and Elizabeth worked
together to foil Kendra's plans and
managed to bring the marker right back
to ages 7. it's here where Kendra ends
up killing Elizabeth as well before the
high mind of the Necromorph takes her
out Isaac fights off the hive mind and
manages to escape ages 7 just in time
before the tectonic load the ishimora
had been holding on to crashes into the
planet causing a catastrophic explosion
just as he begins to relax he's attacked
by what's either the true Necromorph
Nicole or another hallucination of her
and the game ends
so there you have the story of Dead
Space remake if you played the first
game what did you think of some of the
major story changes such as the major
addition with Dr cross a lot of the
writing was also changed and for my part
I actually really prefer this version of
Kendra as she seems far more human and
less cartoonishly evil I hope you
enjoyed and I'll see you guys next time